so along the note of that visual cues
so i've touched on the parentheses and
the ellipsis and of course the emojis i
want you guys to really start thinking
about how you write the same way you
think about food right so how it looks
on the plate
totally is part of the appetizing you
know process
and writing is the same way how it looks
on the screen
we often forget that we have some
amazing tools all of us do in our in our
tool kits on the keyboard or the keypad
so
whether it's numbers so using the number
itself you don't have to write out 23
use
you know two three um or or um
m dashes or brackets slashes
all capital letters all these things
italics
give you the ability to really wield the
power of that of that keyboard
over the pen so to speak with that
authority we were talking about before
and to communicate
your voice the persona that you want
people to understand
and trust and um you know open their
wallets to right
that trust thing we've talked about it a
few times here and i'll keep bringing it
up because
trust is the commodity that we all wield
whether it's on
social or when you're slacking with your
team
and so it's really important to think
about how people are perceiving the
words that you write in order to
get them to do what you want them to do